we've heard a lot about the human cost
of the opioid epidemic according to the
Centers for Disease Control more than
106 thousand Americans die from a drug
overdose in 2021 nearly 17 000 of those
deaths came as a result of prescription
opioids the epidemic has also had huge
economic costs to cities and towns
across the country and now many are in
the process of suing businesses all
along the prescription supply chain from
the pharmaceutical companies that make
the drugs to the stores that sell them
billions of dollars are on the table but
can that money help resolve the problem
Jonathan Vigliotti reports
the streets were Sam Lawrence once lived
may not look like an expensive San
Francisco neighborhood but there is a
high price for living here this is what
drugs took me to yeah this is this is
what I got I chose this
you know in a lot of ways
I didn't have the power of choice but in
some ways I did
drug addiction in San Francisco streets
and hidden in homes would need 8.1
billion dollars to rectify according to
claims made in a federal court case the
city of San Francisco sued drug
companies marketers and pharmacies
alleging they get people hooked with
legal prescription opioid drugs in the
first place at the age of 18 started
using prescription drugs that's just
Progressive
you know starts out fun
occasional you become dependent and then
you physically need the drugs in order
to be to do anything many also end up at
the city's General Hospital which is why
emergency room director Dr Chris
Caldwell testified in the federal case
it would be hard for me to describe a
greater crisis in medicine than what we
face with the opioid epidemic what does
that look like day to day for you so I
don't do a shift
without seeing multiple different
aspects of the opioid crisis so we'll
see the acute overdose where somebody
has taken too much either intentionally
or accidentally we also see the
devastating effects of long-term opioid
use and what the patients will describe
as such an intense need to get that high
again people sometimes develop an image
of what they think of as an a person
with opioid use disorder and I promise
you that it impacts every type of
background or area of life that you can
possibly imagine Emergency Care is just
a part of the cost San Francisco City
attorney David Chu wants to recover and
his office reached a settlement with two
opioid manufacturers allergen antiva in
which they must pay 54 million dollars
to San Francisco over the next 15 years
still pending is the city's case against
Walgreens I've heard of doctors being
pursued for their role in prescribing
these drugs it it's not so often you
hear pharmacies being targeted why go
after pharmacies and I imagine that
there's some difficulty and challenges
that you discover along the way while
pursuing Walgreens sure well we actually
brought this lawsuit to go after the
entire opioid industry but specifically
around around Walgreens I'll say that
our lawsuit was a Bellwether case in
part because it was the first bent trial
not only to find the opioid industry
liable but specifically to find the
pharmacy Walgreens liable for what they
did to our community among thousands of
communities around the country San
Francisco's opioid lawsuit is just one
of 3 300 brought by state and local
governments across the country to make
the opioid industry pay up and already
there have been 54 billion dollars in
settlements most of the money is
designated to addiction treatment and
prevention the numbers are really like
small parking tickets they're really not
creating any incentive for change
University of Maryland Professor Lisa
vertinski studies the impact of large
class action settlements so the money is
largely going to address the harms that
have been caused as opposed to
being invested kind of in more systemic
efforts to prevent that kind of harm
occurring again in the future for Sam
Lawrence his days addicted to drugs and
living on the streets have ended but it
was not because of legal settlements he
ultimately credits a support system of
friends so I spent some years working
with my buddy Quinn in treatment and now
I've made a transition into doing
construction work I spend time with my
family and I go to the gym and I go to
work and
I make sure to participate in my
self-help groups I help others
and the settlement with Walgreens could
come as early as next week the company
declined our request for comment tiva
meanwhile in a statement said its
settlement is quote not an omission of
liability or wrongdoing for CBS Saturday
morning Jonathan Vigliotti in San
Francisco